ya excellé d'audience sur le marché
quand je
continuerai
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
le soir même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
gc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc je suis mère malade je sors
à
quand je joue à gauche
qui sont ils
ça
[Applaudissements]
paquebot pas la coupe points les boys
band dance et côte-à-côte pas l'un sur
l'autre les autonomies son problème
c'est ça ton corps c'est pas faux m'a
dit je vais être appelée tiba nature à
noter
que
j'adore j'adore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reste maintenant
je touche esclaves et c'est tant mieux
me
en fibres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ces experts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je le vois
demers gegants
à
[Musique]
le jeu
que j'ai
passionnément
allons de soi que nous notre camp
[Musique]
impossible
c'est bon c'est bon
aucun
[Musique]
quelques années
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dalia km by la
carte à fond on est en direct une
spéciale boys band pendant encore cinq
minutes je dis bien cinq minutes partir
un jour tu vas le faire s'inquiète pas
[Applaudissements]
vous
tu
vois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ses
souvenirs
oui
au sud est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
j
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les tête à tête
d'or
[Applaudissements]
j'en fais moi c'est bon
mais les médias ont fait plus du tout
mais après tu vois bien la barque et
quoi à la danse c'est vrai ce bordel de
merde or c'est quoi la prochaine je sais
pas
d'argent je pense qu'une envie de jyske
one
way ah ouais alors voilà deux qui sauve
toi tu n'as aucune fille au monde est
plus belle que toi c'est bien ça et je
suis raide dingue de la douane de
bâle et c'est parti bien sûr jusque là
jamais ça démarre comme ça je suis raide
dingue de toi raide dingue car tu vois
tes l'a fait jusque là je la mets
l'amour c'est moi cela m'est encore pris
ces proportions là
[Applaudissements]
c'est coiffure à gueye pas quoi
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le regard droit là attention regarde
envoyer les mecs
tu vois c'est la première pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'amour chez moi il n'avait temps qu'a
pris ces proportions
ah bon soir
je ne m'imaginais pas
sa mort pourrait aller jusque là
à
je suis raide dingue de toi mettre un
quart du bois
fois pour moi
[Applaudissements]
hu
l'afrique
là bas
j'adore
ça là
bas nos pages que le mur à tous cas ce
qui est sûr je ne produirait pas si j'ai
pas envie de perdre de l'argent
on a quoi m était le clou voulait l'en
but mais tout ça
[Musique]
trois ans venu en ami pour connu l'agent
de voix
et
ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hu
et bas
ouais
[Musique]
c'est
ouah
mais moi
[Musique]
la prime
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire figurer comme mama
nationale bien non c'est vrai quoi le
canadien patrick attaque s'est assuré à
la matmut
[Applaudissements]
ses bas alors lé chili on a fait une
dernière après vie cette chaussure y'a
que la vérité qui compte
il ya une personne qui sera derrière ce
rideau une personne qui veut parler à
mathieu
n'a pas fini de deux sacs et
t'as pas fini de transpirer mon bébé way
est pour l'instant un dernier sont pour
vous à chez vous à 18h56 salle on aime
la vie on aime chanter on aime danser et
on aime les beaux éphèbes
ces partis mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ni les sommets dans la cua ce que
j'imagine mais ce que je crois
je fais toutes mes 17 ans touchaient des
paiements qui sont autant de chances au
sein de mead et chantage
desjardins com
je
sais que
[Applaudissements]
à force de tuer
une fois ces jeux
quand laissé dans les choix
ça
non
[Applaudissements]
tandja
m
tous
à
ce que deux
on est bien que les deux
[Applaudissements]
aient pu ramasser non parce qu'on est
membre de donner les dates de mykonos
[Rires]
têtus les tout petits avec un gros
j'ai pas de paddle incarner mathieu jim
quinn est un tout et il ajouté
c'est pitoyable danseur étoile accélère
espérer
ohlala
[Applaudissements]
sympa
il y a
[Musique]
hier
[Applaudissements]
et
loire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout simple passé
[Musique]
m
est chaud
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon